bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue sur
diagonale cette semaine actualitté eloi
encore une fois très joli très chargé et
notamment à paris
oui à paris nous avons eu cette semaine
un superbe événement qui n'est pas un
tournoi d'échecs pour une fois mais qui
concerne de très près le roi des jeux
alors les jeux puisque donc c'était le
75e anniversaire de la fédération
internationale des échecs avec donc la
présence des meilleurs joueurs du monde
notamment les deux champions notamment
les deux champions champions que sont
alexander kalichman dont on ne verra une
interview tout à l'heure et que si vous
ne la championne du monde en titre
chinoise donc c'est une oscillation on a
vu aussi le vice-champion du monde
l'admira copiant le vice champion du
monde cadet
laurent frayssinet qui était présent ce
plus facile pour lui de venir à paris
peut-être que pour que pour as copiant
que pour kalichman puisqu'on peut dire
c'est une jolie manifestation
peut-être maintenant que deux médias
traditionnels je dirais enfin tout cas
grand public
français aux idées clairement l'accent
n'a pas été mis sur la promotion de cet
événement qui en lui même je dirais n'a
rien d'intéressant visa parce qu'on va
convoyer dire est ce qu'il vacille
sur le plan sportif ça n'a aucun intérêt
il n'y a pas de match qui se déroule
c'est juste une conférence de presse
alors on y apprend plein de choses sur
sur pierre sané lieu mis 9 sur le dos de
la fidh est en général c'était les
championnats du monde organisés tout
genre de choses mais il n'y a pas de
partie d'échecs donc pour les passionnés
du jeu pur
ce n'était pas un événement qui méritait
d'être vu maintenant ce qui s'y est dit
mérite vraiment d'être racontée et
détaillé alors notamment
je ne sais pas si on va pouvoir lancer
tout de suite la première la première
interview mais donc on a donc quand on a
vu encore une fois parce que c'est pas
la première fois qu'on le voit sauter
bonal le président de la fédération
française des échecs donc été à
jean-claude loubatière eloi qui encore
une fois est ce se place toujours
d'aller dans les événements comme sa
place la fédération et met en valeur le
jeu d'échecs en france oui chacun chaque
événement organisé par la fédération
française d'échecs et sous le patronage
dirait de jean-claude loubatières ici il
était l'un en tant que président de
séance c'est à dire qu'il distribue la
parole aux journalistes il gérait un peu
après la séance
donc de la fidh et en langue française
puisque cette en france et donc il
dirige et il pose en finlande serrant
squad ici on l'a interviewé il va nous
en parler donc voilà si on peut envoyer
le président de la fédération française
jean claude douba tiers on peut pas non
plus pas on ne peut pas voilà c'est pas
calé bon c'est pas grave on va y arriver
alors autre événement on va y revenir
tout la partie c'est la fin du match
entre quatre chefs seuls quatre chefs
est donc vain der wiel le hollandais
avec finalement un score attendu
peut-être au départ mais quand même très
bon pour le pour le franco kazakh
alors je ne dirais pas attendu puisque
personnellement je pensais que le match
allait être vraiment très très équilibré
que le score final aurait dû être à peu
près 6 4 ou 5 et demi quatre et demi on
sait pas trop pour qu'ils reflètent sa
catch est bien entendu était favori
maintenant le score final ressent quand
même une dirait une sorte de boucherie
en fait il faut bien le dire puisqu'il a
donc quatre chefs et 17 à 3 700 même un
score énorme il lui met 4.4.3 une seule
défaite donc une défaite 5 victoires
donc c'est vraiment c'est un vraiment du
beau jeu
en plus la pureté des partis est
vraiment superbe donc on va revenir ça
en fin d'émission puisqu'on va une
position je crois et loi de la huitième
partie une très jolie partie peut-être
la plus belle d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
si c'est vrai moi j'ai trouvé que
c'était elle était très jolie
disons qu'il est bien parce qu'elle est
courte ça c'est ça c'est un bon élément
pour cette partie une assez belle
victoire donc de quatre chefs qui est la
dernière qui a un peu marqué l'arrêt du
match puisqu'ils ont fini par inertie
avec deux nuls assez rapides donc en
fait le score était de 6 2 et s'est
terminée avec deux parties nulles chacun
prenant donc dans deux parties au point
avec la spéciale de ça si on peut
envoyer jean-claude matière maintenant
donc le président de la fédération
française toujours 75e anniversaire de
la fédération internationale des échecs
automobile club de france place de la
concorde à paris dont seront maintenant
le président de la fédération française
des échecs bonjour le prêt monsieur le
président bonjour comment ça se passe
75e anniversaire les projets
le bihan le 75e anniversaire c'est
d'abord célébré le passé donc il ya 75
ans la fédération internationale été
créée à paris par quatorze nations à
l'initiative d'un français qui était
pierre vincent la fédération française a
été créée depuis trois ans déjà
en 24 pierre vincent a voulu rassembler
les pays et donc de ceux ci est née la
véritable structure de compétition qui
existe à l'heure actuelle enfin notez
aussi que la langue officielle de la
fédération je crois que c'est bien sûr
le français il me semble parce que quand
même le français quand il a eu cette
idée là il a appelé d'abord la fille des
bains la fédération internationale des
échecs donc le nom c'est un nom français
et puis la langue officielle c'était le
français les idées sont bien française
toujours lors qu'elles sont maintenant
les projets on voit que
on a appris la aujourd'hui qui auraient
des problèmes cette année pour que les
grands tournois comme linares par
exemple ne se fasse pas cette année on
va se poser la question est ce que le
prochain championnat du monde de la fidh
et va avoir lieu le prochain championnat
du monde de la fidh et va avoir lieu oui
je crois que oui parce que il y a un
sponsor qui est un sponsor unique qui
s'appelle kirsten il imagine of donc il
est toujours là donc a priori de jeu
championnat aura lieu
c'est clair donc ce n'est pas du tout
pareil que pour les tournois privés et
maintenant d'une manière plus générale
sur l'évolution des échecs je crois que
il y à une évolution qui est qui existe
qui se fait et en france en particulier
pour gagner de l'argent pour que les
professionnels gagnent de l'argent il
faut qu'il y ait des compétitions un peu
différente des grands tournois parce que
les grands tournois c'est une chose mais
il faut des sponsors qui sont en réalité
des mécènes dans la mesure où le public
est quand même encore relativement
limitée
par contre il ya d'autres voies il y a
par exemple des championnats de clubs
dans chaque pays
bon l'allemagne a commencé la france a
suivi
et puis après maintenant d'autres
arriveront en angleterre espagne et donc
je crois que c'est un moyen de gagner sa
vie et de faire vivre les professionnels
donc il faut chercher d'autres voies
plutôt que les anciens critères
par exemple aussi des tournants
spectacle voilà donc ça c'était à la
perche est lancé bien sûr je crois que
létourneau spectacle ils doivent avoir
des caractéristiques patte particulière
donc le public ne peut pas attendre
pendant dix jours 6 heures pour regarder
les parties c'est difficile donc
effectivement le jeu rapide c'est une
voie nouvelle et donc ça nous fédération
française des échecs on va le développer
très fortement et dans le monde entier
je pense que c'est la voie d'avoir des
spectateurs aussi par le fait que les
jeux d'échecs et de plus en plus connue
par les jeunes et donc il faut qu'ils
les gens même s'ils ne vont pas dans un
club d'échecs même s'ils ne font pas de
la compétition
il est important que les gens aient du
plaisir à regarder une partie d'échecs
et soit le public de demain en fait dans
les écoles nous en france je dis
toujours conforme le public de demain
dernière question je reviens au
championnat du monde des échecs les
tommaso nous ne sont toujours pas connus
ne sont toujours pas organisé est ce
qu'il ya des informations pour nous
notre zone le championnat aura
probablement lieu en septembre
et donc j'ai des candidats intéressés
donc je pense que c'est une bonne
période parce que c'est une période où
il n'y a pas trop de tournois open ça
gêne pas les autres compétitions et
tournois zone à lille est bien bien
calés donc c'est quelque chose qui
intéresse les organisateurs et qui
intéresse les joueurs dans la mesure où
il ya le jackpot après qui suit pour le
champion du monde c'est président merci
voilà donc eloi jean-claude matière qui
nous donne est donc ici
un panel assez étendue finalement deux
thèmes reliés au jeu d'échecs et
entendra parler du tournez dares on a
parlé des prochaines tournoi zone où en
tête a expliqué ce que c'est on
réexplique et du championnat du monde
et puis d'autres thèmes comme ça
intéressant oui non la première nouvelle
quand même c'est que linares sera peut
être annulée donc ça on y reviendra dans
l'émission mais ce gros tournoi qui dure
depuis dix ans au moins invitant
régulièrement les meilleurs joueurs du
monde et peut-être annulé l'autre
information c'est qu'il a parlé des
tournois zonaux alors ça on va on peut y
revenir le tournoi zonal c'est ce qui
s'organise au niveau de l'europe
l'europe contenant à peu près six ou
sept zones je ne sais pas exactement
combien est donc la zone 1 a et la zone
qui inclut la france la belgique les
anglais les espagnols donc zone assez
forte et donc ils vont parler de
l'accusation de sa fonction de la force
de la zone
on a plus on a un nombre de qualifiés
pour le championnat du monde tout
simplement
donc c'est de l'étape juste avant le
championnat du monde avec les 100
joueurs comme la banque la caixa
c'était la question c'est est ce que ces
tournois zone où vont avoir lieu puisque
pour l'instant pas aucune date n'est
connue et la réponse c'est
qu'effectivement il s'est déjà en route
en fait l'organisation est en route
oui c'est hier qu'on connaît le système
ne connais pas les dates actuellement on
pense qu'ils auront un championnat du
monde qui aura lieu avant la fin de
l'année 2000 oui avant la fin de l'année
2000 donc là jean-claude matières
proposées dans les guides et les
tournois solos en septembre 2002 voilà
me tiens déjà des candidats
c'est ce qui expliquait avec a priori ça
devrait ça devrait pouvoir se faire
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est à
dire que le chante la demande nouvelle
formule devrait pouvoir se pérenniser
est ce qu'ils ont vu en tout cas autres
thèmes intéressants ils ont parlé de
paris aussi donc du développement des
jeux du jeu rapide en france détournant
spectacle et je crois que cette année va
y avoir de beaux tournois et notamment
les l'appui de la fédération
il va y avoir du beau jeu puisque
en ce moment on est en train de mettre
au point en donc l'équipe de diagonale
plus la fédération française d'échecs
éventuellement de mettre au point un
circuit de tournois rapide donc le
premier étant le grand prix de bordeaux
qui est qui est déjà plus ou moins
pérenniser puisque ça va être sa
quatrième édition avec un circuit qui
passerait donc par montpellier pour
arriver finalement à paris la ville la
plus belle du monde et bastia bastia qui
dans le passé ont éventuellement parmi
ce lot qui s'est livré aussi comme une
étape importante dans les basses terres
ils ont clairement le savoir-faire il y
en a vu un match macro polgar très très
bien fait très très bien organisée donc
tout ça c'est des villes qui sont
candidates a justement promouvoir le jeu
par ses échecs spectacle ses échecs
rapide ces déchets qui peuvent captiver
un public qui ne demande pas mieux
tilda alors le prochain chantier animal
et un bruit de fond seront quoi ça
pourrait se passer en chine et on a
rencontré la semaine dernière
la championne du monde féminine kyun
c'est quand même quelqu'un ça fait elle
a déjà été championne du monde et
quelques années avait perdu son titre
contre 6 ha pour le gard ou peut-être
pas mais enfin là peut-être pas
directement campagne afin de laver perdu
et donc là elle a récupéré son titre
donc
la championne du monde chinoises sinoun
surya bonaly donc 75e anniversaire de la
fidh et nous sommes maintenant avec la
championne du monde féminine
si ou non
gowlings seyoun so you i want you my
world title google yahoo china la
roumanie pour les victimes
une avancée sociale non oui de rythme
baisse to promote chaise espèce de
michel simon activities and day one more
time you say partners caisse spécifique
in china et y vivre y aille
oui nova tv the little time is also with
my way that such as i am a man show
johnny chan et hash annoncé la nasa
james quinn somme ce coup du sort de
cannes
l'ofj mais est ce que ce match six
nouvelles yoplait horneck stature les
divisions européennes celles actives
animaux et non comme un stade et 5e
match j'aime m'amuser doigt parce que le
son est un peu décalé quand ton décalé
entre intervieweur et interviewé oui
c'est à dire que l'interviewer c'était
toi oui et donc tu te mets ton niveau
très très près de ta bouche en tout cas
et
doxi dont il était un peu plus distant
mais alors j'ai pas bien compris en fait
à la fin de l'interview
oui je pense qu'elle a dit qu'elle
n'était pas professionnelle de chèque ou
en tout cas qu'elle voulait poursuivre
ses études à leur gré comme en chine
donc répondre à cette interview quel jeu
la question c'est est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'elle va faire peut promouvoir les
échecs est ce qu'elle va jouer en europe
à ce qu'elle va faire donc un certain
nombre de tournois d'exhibition et elle
disait que en fait non elle voulait se
concentrer plus précisément dans ces
études donc fait ça c'est une nouvelle
en fait parce qu'on pourrait s'attendre
à ce que la championne du monde
participe à des tournois est en fait
tombé là le dit clairement qu'elle
préfère continuer ses études
oui donc un avis et un évier ça c'est
révélateur d'un certain malaise des
échecs féminin je dirais puisque si la
championne du monde veut poursuivre ses
études
ouais scolaire ya un problème quelque
part je sais ce que tu as colère lorsque
ça me dit je pense qu'elle doit être à
l'université quand même oui donc donc
c'était quand même intéressant aussi on
a parlé de
les parmi les questions c'était le
développement des échecs en chine on a
déjà parlé
suite à son voyage à pékin et là on en
reparle encore une fois c'est le
confirme qu'effectivement c'est la
grande ruée vers l'or de l'esprit où on
fait un là-bas oui ça on en a déjà parlé
dans diagonale c'est clair que les
échecs en chine ne demande qu'à
s'améliorer puisque il ya beaucoup de
joueurs il ya des structures et il n'y a
pas la tradition qui est en train de lui
en train de s'acquérir finalement il
joue de plus en plus il joue de mieux en
mieux
là les chinois commencent à être très
fort vraiment très fort et donc c'est ce
que je dis dans europe et cheikh le
troisième millénaire sera chinois
enfin les chiffres de ventes ont démarré
alors ça c'est pas sur moi je pense que
l'histoire français étienne jacques
romann champion du monde
enfin on va essayer en tout cas on va
devoir donc si oui ou non on va bientôt
voir le champion du monde et donc ça
c'est deux très grandes vignes en figure
évidemment forcément de l'année on a eu
beaucoup de titres de l'année alors
pourquoi on en parle parce que les lois
tuent à préparer la sortie donc de dunes
j'ai supervisé un produit dérivé pendant
l'émission diagonale alors qu'est ce que
c'est c'est très simple en fait c'est un
best-of de l'année 1999 les 50 émissions
qu'on a fait depuis septembre décembre
1998 qui se regroupent sous la forme de
cette cassette merveilleuse de caisse
est un secret très joli est-ce qu'on
peut le revoir
je vais passer la caméra peut la voir
voilà le best-of 99
donc c'est à englobe tous les meilleurs
moments de diagonale les interviews des
meilleurs joueurs ou le dos je suis pas
sûr ne vaut un meilleur joueur qu'on y
interviewer notamment
vladimir kramnik non c'est à dire non
non c'est à nantes
j'en ai tellement fait je viens juste de
la terminer là je suis planeur shirov
qu'est ce qu'on peut lire judith moi
j'irai quoi le gars qui met des grands
tournois bastien dortmund au goût vers
les bains ou gun avec à la fin de la
cassette deux parties commentées en
intégralité
qui sont les parties donc cartes peuvent
paul gaillard et bdf skikda crocs voilà
donc cette cassette et disponible vous
pouvez donc que vous avez les
coordonnées de
notre dame des distributeurs cette
cassette en cliquant à droite de
l'émission sur le bouton b juste devant
le best-of 99
voilà donc les meilleurs moments compilé
de toute l'année ça a été long je crois
qu'il y avait 50 plus de 50 heures de
programmes 50 heures de rushes à faire
en plus réussir à donner une cohérence à
l'ensemble pour qu'on découvre l'année
avec un certain plomb une certaine
approche est donc finalement le tout
tient dans cette cassette vhs ccam de 91
minutes exactement que je vous encourage
donc si vous appréciez d'émissions à
regarder puisque c'est quand même je
dirais pas que c'est mieux que
l'émission mais c'est très bon également
voilà best-of catherine staff des gones
al donc la publicité est fini on va
passer maintenant à bien au cours de
l'émission le champion du monde de 1999
alexander kalichman pour la première
fois dans diagonale on l'a rencontré la
semaine dernière voilà mais je vous
laisse découvrir cette interview du
champion du monde nous sommes ici à
l'automobile club de france pour le 75e
anniversaire de la fédération
internationale nous avons la chance
d'avoir avec nous le champion du monde
d'échecs alexander qualif man so
alexander qualif manana roulante
hao tôt improve rim gers veut ni rio 22
geste avec 1 900 mhz contre 8,27 inverse
bat v monstre généraux m is to remove
rice politisation franç ais fin de tout
remind de manipur est chercheuse
m'entendre les i ce scandale huit
chauffeurs en chef durant la soirée
excitante de valley
claire game versailles saint petersbourg
chase co ce match est fou internet tout
neuf au mas 3 milliard
mt 10 bykov audience internet de vitra
est une provocation de world was too old
games match de hockey samedi note
monster leader sur les étapes
compétition
un rail de vérité
we have seen la texture pertinament live
et casey linares une sonate de liszt
africans imitation on bat hockey à le
suivre de nouveaux tests
il faut il faut encore une boue des
postes unis general and isles expecting
toutes les problématiques 13 décembre à
paris ok
un exemple type will have and symbolic
président cette année compliquée
j'espère franchir man cinquième match
voilà donc aujourd'hui je retiens mon
souffle compte il a proposé parce que
c'est vrai que le champion du monde
c'est quelque chose
d'ailleurs j'étais un peu nerveux sur
cette interview comme tu as pu le noter
beaucoup de choses intéressantes en tout
cas oui énormément de choses alexander
califano a beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
dire c'est pas un champion du monde
standard on peut dire que c'est le 14e
champion du monde en tout cas il se
considère pas comme étant joueur
professionnel ce qui est quand même
assez assez rigolo à entendre nos deux
champions du monde actuel sont
qu'est ce qu'il fait il en île à une
école d'échecs sur internet
il cherche quand même à développer le
jeu il s'agit s'oriente vers le jeu
rapide je dirais qu est ce qui nous a
dit lorsque nous aigner dans autre chose
il à dire énormément de choses il a
parlé du niveau de las vegas encore une
fois il a rappelé que mais évidemment il
y avait pas kasparov
il n'y avait pas car pauvre mais tous
les autres étaient là et annonce il
n'était pas la face et étroit qui était
pas là ont même si c'est effectivement
trois gros mais il y avait beaucoup
d'autres et donc quand on considère qu
évidemment le niveau était très relevé
jusqu'aux sûr qu'on est d'accord je
prends donc essayez donc très content
d'avoir gagné ce tournoi malgré des
conditions climatiques et las vegas
difficile c'est ce qu'il a dit est ce qu
elle c'est vrai qu'il fait très très
chaud au moins d'août la braconne on est
très très chaud à las vegas mais en tout
cas il a aussi mentionné l'aspect
financier du tournoi qui est quand même
une chose qui je n'irai qui turlupine la
majorité des joueurs en tout cas des
joueurs professionnels
ça mérite d'être mentionné c'est que
tous les joueurs qui ont passé plus que
deux tours c'est à dire les groupes riz
en fait n'ont pas été payés pour les
stars enfin disons que pour l'instant
alors alexander qu'un espace bien
entendu cautionne la fidh et on est en
fait mais simplement sur le compte d'un
léger problème de trésorerie qu'il
assimile à un manque de pratique de
l'organe de l'organisation l'a fait
c'est vrai que c'est quand même
seulement la deuxième édition de ce
championnat
donc ils sont excusables pour l'instant
de toute façon leur tournoi est assez
joli quand même assez spectaculaire en
tout cas au niveau des éliminations
directes internationaux système tout à
fait donc je pense moins que c'est une
bonne chose alexander klein a l'air de
bien cautionner le championnat est en
tout cas un championnat c'est
intéressant parce que il a une belle
voix il est assez beau c'est un grand
blond et en plus il est motivé pour
pour populariser le jeu d'échecs qui est
quand même là une bonne chose une bonne
chose à faire notamment pour le champion
du monde alors on est revenu encore une
fois à ce niveau là c'est historiquement
c'est lui qui nous avait donné l'oreille
au départ du tour na li na reste sous
qui n'existent pas alors la question
c'était c'est le nouveau champion du
monde avec un système qui est
controversée est ce que les
organisateurs des grands tournois
mondiaux
vont limiter cette année la question
c'était ça pourquoi parce qu'avec 1/2 et
on a remarqué
moi j'avais remarqué en tout cas qu'il
n'était pas sur la liste donc la
question c'était avait-il reçu
d'invitation et s'il avait reçu pourquoi
il avait refusé et la réponse c'est
qu'il avait effectivement reçu une
invitation
donc c'est bon signe c'est à dire que on
a reconnu sa grande prestation quand
même et par contre qu'il a refusé parce
qu'il va jouer il avait prévu déjà de
jouer contre peter l'écho un match début
janvier juste avant ce tournant là alors
excusez moi je crois que mélanger deux
tonneaux mais je vais peut-être me
tromper non non il faudrait bien match
contre peter l'écho il le match capital
et causer quand j'ai parlé non pas par
les lignes arrières d'accord avec adidas
et un autre chose c'est le méga tournoi
en espagne c'est vrai c'est vrai l'aïe a
vite vu qu'andy qui va mieux du 14 au 28
janvier où on aura d'ailleurs kasparov
oui j'espère le donc le meilleur joueur
du monde cette fois et il était
effectivement il a reçu une invitation
pour jouer ce tournoi d'une force
extrait extrêmement relevé c'est un
catégorie 18 ou 19 qui veut dire que
parmi les dix meilleurs mondiaux il y en
aura au moins six qui participeront là
bas donc c'est vraiment un très gros
tournoi il a reçu une invitation pour
jouer ça mais ayant déjà accepté de voir
m peter les causes justes avant ouais le
champion du monde ne s'éparpille pas
c'est à dire qu'il a fait il a fait son
choix et rezé tient ses engagements et
joue contre les co et annule donc le
tournoi devait y kanza nul donc alors
que peter l'écho non leurs critères les
colis a confirmé sa participation mais
quand j'ai quand même
il est jeune mais risque voilà ils
risquent d'être fatigué c'est le risque
est ce que effectivement un match après
un match contre cannes hickman surtout
que c'est hyper donc c'est très mauvais
pour le moral il risque faire une
prestation en demi teinte avec un dès
maintenant c'est peter légaux et il a
démontré à une arrière que il approche
les meilleurs du monde
voyez donc ça c'est pour l'actualité de
janvier et nathan février le tournoi
dinars s le suspense est entier nous
avons donc interrogé une personne très
concerné par l'événement
oui est-ce que de grands noms à linares
aura lieu la question suppose kalichman
parce qu'ils espéraient bien je le
jouais c'était considéré comme le plus
grand tournoi du monde
réponse d'une personne qui probablement
parmi les mieux placés qui est le
président de la fédération espagnole des
échecs
javier otxoa et chaouen et bien toujours
75e anniversaire de la fidh et nous
sommes maintenant avec le président de
la fédération espagnole des échecs
javier otxoa et chaouen votre langue
bonjour monsieur le président peut-être
vous pouvez nous dire l'état des échecs
en espagne on sait que les
agne l'espagne a beaucoup d'aficion
qu'on dit pour les échecs l'espagne et
l'hiver à l'organisation de tournois
avec cheikh et maintenant on a noté
beaucoup de projets avec l'échec à mon
pays et spécialement il ya beaucoup de
progrès entre les jeunes et je pense que
son importance et l'organisation des
championnats du monde des moins de 17
ans et 114 1 200 puissants pendant trois
années
nous avons là et savons là
l'organisation avait concédé pour la
fidh et et je pense que ça va développer
beaucoup mais si cheikh en espagne
beaucoup plus encore le champion du
monde alexandre à khalifa nous a dit
qu'il était probable que cette année le
tournoi de linares seraient annulés
est-ce que vous confirmer cette
information vient les informations que
j'ai de la veine erreurs se sont pas
tout à fait clair je pense qu'il ya
encore des possibilités de faire les
tournages et l'ineris et il faut
attendre de savoir exactement ce qui va
passer mais j'ai écouté parler qu'il y à
un démon possibilités encore est-ce que
l'espagne est candidate pour
l'organisation du prochain championnat
du monde qui aura lieu en novembre de
l'année prochaine
non malheureusement ne sont pas
candidats et nous avons beaucoup de
candidates il faut des centres et tourne
à décider et par exemple en espagne et
les championnats du monde amateurs et
aussi les championnats d'europe juniors
les championnats du monde des moins de
18 ans se sent encore et
on a beaucoup d project mai
vraiment pour les championnats du monde
individuels et nous n'avons pas
présentés et aucun poste j'ai président
remercie donc voilà il a fait le tour
des grands tournois d'espagne le
président de la fédération espagnole
donc cette fois est donc en fait sa
réponse sur le temps lennar sc qu' il
est donc en fait pas encore sûr que ça
va être annulé il fallait attendre
encore deux semaines donc c'est la
semaine dernière on a encore une semaine
d'attentes pour savoir si les
tractations qui sont en cours avec
d'éventuels sponsors complémentaires
pourront aboutir
oui c'est exactement ça c'est c'est ce
qu'a dit javier otxoa des chanoines donc
bon bah le tourneau dinas aura-t-il lieu
on le saura bientôt
merci la palpation chose à dire s'il a
pas lieu à mon avis c'est quand même
coup dur pour les échecs
oui c'est un coup dur ça veut dire que
le temps d'un n'a pas été pérennisée
parce qu'un tournoi qui commence depuis
dix ans donc à tourner à kiev qui a
depuis dix ans s'il s'arrête c'est
vraiment qu'il n'a pas été fait sur des
bases solides
puisqu'il n'y a aucune raison quand on
s'arrête après 10 ans d'existence
si si tout a été fait comme il le
fallait bon maintenant luis ribeiro ses
propres tête ses propres coups de coeur
ses excès qu'on lui connaît alors s'ils
n'arrêtent n'a pas lieu ça sera ça sera
un choix de sa part à mon avis et non
pas un manque de savoir faire
on verra donc envers en aura sûrement
des nouvelles d'ici quelques semaines
voilà alors quelqu'un de très
intéressant maintenant par rapport aux
championnats du monde officiel saignant
mais avait échappé la demande officielle
jeunes oui c'est à dire que là on a fait
un point sur le futur
maintenant on va revenir un peu sur le
passé avec notre
entre un autre comment ça s'appelle un
petit noir vendre notre petite star le
jeune petit est gentil laurent laurent
frayssinet qui revient sur son
championnat du monde des moins de 18 ans
si on peut l'envoyer jouera tous nous
sommes 8 place de la concorde à
l'automobile club de france avec avec
nous aujourd'hui
le vice champion du monde cadet laurent
frayssinet bonjour laurent bonjour aloi
donc on parle beaucoup de toi dans
diagonale
alors comment as tu fait pour terminer
premiers ex-aequo en fait de ceux de ce
tournoi extrêmement fort qu'est le
championnat du monde des moins de 18 ans
ben disons j'ai essayé de donner le
meilleur de moi-même aux deux premières
manches assez mal parti j'ai fait deux
nuls et ça m'a permis de mettre dans le
bain en jouant des adversaires un peu
moins fort jusqu'à la sixième ronde et
après j'ai joué donc les favoris du
tournoi et comme j'étais en bonne forme
j'ai fait un bon résultat et donc j'ai
fait j'ai réussi à faire en huit
émissions 11 tu es tu n'as pas perdu
deux parties fidèle à ton style solide
voilà j'ai pas peur une partie j'ai fait
quelques nuls rapide avec les noirs
j'avais fait deux exactement et avec les
blancs j'essayais de de jouer des
parties d'attac pour pour essayer de
gagner
et pourquoi la dernière ronde alors que
tu peux gagner le tournoi si tu gagnes
cette partie pourquoi n'as tu pas joué
son va-tout effet nul
il me semble assez rapide j'ai fait nul
assez rapide quand même trente coups ce
qui est quand même la position j'étais
un petit peu mieux mais il se trouvait
que le russe qui jouait à côté de moi
qui avait huit points aussi j'avais huit
points avaient un meilleur des partages
que moi et avait une meilleure position
que soit l'adversaire et donc il avait
probablement gagner et si je gagnais
j'étais premier ex-aequo il était
premier au départage vu qu'on avait
calculé des partages et si je perdais
par contre je me retrouvais 5 ou 6e donc
je me suis dit ça servait à rien de
prendre de risques et assurer la seconde
place vu que je pouvais pas faire mieux
donc tu es logiquement assurer le podium
qu'est ce que tu peux nous dire il
paraît qu'il ya eu un petit jeune là bas
de 12 ans qui était en tête tout le
temps moi qui a été un peu de
révélations est ce que est ce que tu
peux nous en parler un peu justement
c'est mon adversaire de la dernière
ronde et donc il a il était en tête tout
le tournoi il avait cet ennemi sur neuf
je crois et il a perdu à l'avant-dernier
rang contre le russe qui a été champion
du monde mais il a vraiment dominé le
tournoi et
et à 12 ans il à 2450 sait déjà et je
pense qu'il faut déjà plus et il voit
peu près à mon avis de 1500 et même si
je fais une bonne partie contenu et la
dernière ronde
c'est vraiment des futurs grands joueurs
d'accord donc on rappelle que tu es vice
champion du monde cadet une petite
dernière question pour le pour les
internautes qui regardent une question
qui revient très fréquemment commente en
train de tuer et quel que vas tu faire
comment envisages tu ton avenir et chic
donc je m'entraîne avec mon ordinateur
portable et j'essaie de concilier en
fait je vais encore au lycée je suis en
terminale et j'essaie de concilier un
peu les deux en faisant à peu près une
heure une heure quotidienne des chèques
par jour et par contre quand je suis un
tournoi j'essaie vraiment de travailler
beaucoup pour pour essayer de progresser
on rappelle que tu habites à dax il l'a
battu à jouer plusieurs fois le grand
prix de bordeaux
est ce que tu vas le rejouer cette année
en espérant gagner le tournoi et je vais
leur jouer cette année et j'espère je
veux gagner le tournoi même si vraiment
il ya des adversaires très difficiles
laurent frayssinet bravo et merci merci
voilà donc le petit grand pressigny tu
n'as pas trouvé le terme
j'ai lépaule terme en fait petit
freyssinet c'est notre mascotte des
diagonales donc on va s'offrir un petit
freyssinet en plastique que nous
pourrons que nous pourront exhiber pour
présenter cette émission puisque
vraiment c'est un petit un jeune qu'on
aime beaucoup qui joue très très bien
est ce que j'ai bien aimé un propos
qu'il a dit oui c'est quand il a dit le
petit jeune qui joue bien il est déjà
très fort oui c'est en parlant du don
radjabov je crois que c'est radjabov
radjabov un petit ukrainien hors mini me
semble arménien c'est de lui dont il
parle est arménien il a 12 ans ouais et
2450 tout à fait remarquable les
kasparov a fait des éloges de ses sept
enfants
j'ai lu ça je suis plus j'ai pu le faire
aujourd'hui sur el país je crois
d'ailleurs il de toutes façons de 1450
il n'y a pas trop de soucis à se faire
pour ce jeune garçon il va devenir très
très fort sans aucun doute
donc voilà cette interview de laurent
frayssinet donc on va passer maintenant
l'analyse du match 4 chefs dans les
revues bord a déjà dit le résultat au
départ 7 à 3 pour quatre chefs très bon
résultat et je crois que c'est
l'objectif que voulait se donner d'un
mineur le vatican et loi c'est d'amener
la 10e place quatre chefs dans les vingt
premiers mondiaux il est sur la bonne
piste
oui exactement après avoir battu alberto
david 6 à 2 là il s'impose donc contre
john van der wiel 7 à 3 gagnants dans
les deux matchs une dizaine de ponts ce
qui est considérable
il avait déjà 2650 à peu près il va
passer à vergt 2670 l'objectif fixé par
danièle ivancich c'était 2700 points ce
qui le placerait dans les dix meilleurs
mondiaux
ça me paraît un peu tôt pour l'instant
mais après ses deux victoires superbe se
suit vie peut encore faire suivre
quelques temps noir et attendre un
classement qui le placera probablement
dans le top 20 ce qui serait tout à fait
remarquable
donc voilà le district chef on en a déjà
beaucoup parlé la semaine dernière donc
on va pas en remettre une couche
par contre on va voir on va en mettre
une couché vois pas ce qu'on va voir la
huitième partie du match on positionne
la huitième partie puisque comme vous
voyez avec toutes ses interviews on
n'aura pas le temps de faire une analyse
complète et détaillée
alors c'est amusant parce que j'avais
est choisi je crois cette position lundi
il me semble et je crois que la position
je l' ai vu apparaître dans libé
indépendamment en fait elle était
choisie aussi par jean pierre mercier
chroniqueur dans libération et qui nous
écrit temps en temps pour cette émission
donc on est très content mais d'avoir
choisi artistiquement néo là même le
même choix d'avoir fait le même choix
que jean pierre mercier qu'on apprécie
ici beaucoup à diagonale et loi qui est
un excellent chroniqueur
oui c'est clair jean pierre mercier et
créer une rubrique dans libé ration
quotidienne
c'est un travail énorme il faut suivre
l'actualité en permanence depuis très
longtemps déjà
on veut y compris de qualité d'ailleurs
tous les joueurs d'échecs que je connais
hachette libération uniquement pour la
brique échec et viens vivre et
éventuellement pour d'autres aspects de
toute façon jean pierre mercier fait du
très bon travail et de l'itie donc on a
choisi le même segment cuit on
commentera pas toute la partie cette
fois ci pour des raisons de temps le
mans avec l'affluence l'information n'a
été obligé de se limiter à une position
alors peut-être que tu peux rappeler aux
internautes comment faire pour garder
cette partie oui donc pour suivre cette
partie avec nous mais vous allez la voir
sur la vidéo vous avez une deuxième
possibilité pour voir la partie dans son
intégralité ce qui vous donnera devait
d'avoir les premiers coups comment les
joueurs sont arrivés à cette position
et puis vous permettra de voir comment
après la partie s'est terminée
exactement vers la fin donc pour cela
vous pouvez cliquer sur votre page de
droite sur le bouton jouer qui vous
amène donc sur une applet java qui vous
permet donc de voir la partie sur un
logiciel intégré et deuxième possibilité
vous pouvez la partie différée de
diagonale télécharger un logiciel même
petit bouton qui s'appelle soft je veux
essayer pour pc et pour mac et voir
cette partie en cliquant ensuite sur le
fichier pgn en dessous du bouton jouer
qui vous permettra de voir la partie
grâce au logiciel que vous aurez
installé précédemment voilà donc deux
possibilités
l'applet java ou le fichier pgn avec un
logiciel voilà maintenant si on peut
voyez alors dans les deux cas je vous
invite à aller directement au 18e coup
des noirs ces terres les noirs viennent
de jouer au xviiie ou g5 donc là pour ça
vous descendez si vous êtes dans la
planète vous allez au 18e coût est de
même si vous êtes sur n'importe quel
logiciel et on arrive donc à une
position qu'on va commenter en bref donc
déjà aurait mentionné les conforts des
blancs way qui sont ceux du option les
pions des 4 2-3 f4 très très fort qui
donc qui contrôle parfaitement les cases
noires pas très bien en harmonie avec le
fou de cases blanches vous voyez que les
pions contrôler les cases noires le fou
contrôler les cases blanches tout ça
fait un effet très très combiné qui
contrôlent beaucoup de cases le cabinet
c5 très bien passé bien entendu puisque
il contrôle également la caso carte met
la pression sur le fidesz est donc de
toute façon les blancs dans cette
question on l'avantagent ont un avantage
des espaces les noir e en compensation
la paire de fous ont une position droit
qui semblait plus sur ses terres qui
sont le coeur on le plonge et les blancs
n'ont pas et le cavalier en b si ce
n'est pas très bien placé
donc en fait à mon avis avait avantage
blanc et le dernier coup de john van der
veer un mage noir
un avantage non bien sûr à cause de ce
contrôle central qu'on a mentionné dès
le début je pense ici que les blancs ont
un avantage on malgré la sécurité du roi
blanc par rapport à celui du rat noir
oui oui enfin leur disons que ça peut se
discuter dans la mesure où les blancs
une belle perspective ces deux mètres la
tour f 1 angers 1 sur cette très belle
collègue
ne demande qu'à s'ouvrir et ici
vladislav tkachiev après le coup énergie
de john van der wiel g7 g5 contre 18e
coup on le rappelle on trouve une très
très belle combinaison
donc c'était la question de gmp remercie
la question de jean pierre mercier dans
libération les blanchons égal en gros on
peut dire ça les blancs jouent et
gagnent beaucoup beaucoup de matériel
c'est pas si simple à trouver d'accord
c'est même assez difficile d'autant plus
que l'on ne s'y attend pas donc là
l'idée en fait c'est que la dame noire
est un petit peu
en territoire ennemi en fait et pris un
peu dans les pièges voyant là dans une
position resserré on est disons que
l'idée qui a inspiré la combinaison
c'est cette dame noire que je vais
pointer je vais lapointe et on va t-on
vers voila voila je peux pas d'honneur
envers elle a plus de cases sur cet
échiquier regarder on va prendre cette
diagonale la diagonale f5 b1 c'est
qu'elle s'est donnée contrôlé par la
dame blanche case d3 aussi la case au
cap par le cas les c5 la caisse de 5 que
je pense que maintenant et over contrôlé
par deux pions +2/5 allier la caisse des
5 et dans le vent sous le feu de ce fou
congé d'eux et les autres cases ne sont
pas encore disponibles
donc il ya un piège qui se profile et
c'est exactement ce que fait flat des
saf cap chef
elles sont 19e coup 19 cavani h4 calais
h 14 ça libère l'action du fou donc déjà
la dame ne peut plus aller sur la case
des cinq-cantons signaler tout à l'heure
par contre évidemment ça donne un
cavalier sévère ce cavalier est en prise
est en prise par le pion un g5
lecavalier tant pis pour l'option g5y si
oui alors il excusé la manip qui n'a pas
marché
vous voyez l'option g5 peut prendre le
km à 10 h 4 ce cafouillage quatre
attaquants la dame de collecte mais les
noirs ont pas le choix en fait les noirs
n'ont pas le choix ici c est obligé de
prendre du matériel on dirait que les
blancs font exprès on ya des
combinaisons donc ça on essaie d'aider
d'adversaires à gagner là on donne une
pièce et les noirs n'ont pas le choix
les vents n'ont pas le choix donc très
logiquement johnny van der wiel prend la
pièce la pièce emprise et maintenant
continuer la petite combinaison avec
fous en 4 et là on s'aperçoit que le g
d'appliquer une case et oui alors donc
on est 20e coup les blancs viennent de
je me fous aux quatre contrôlant toutes
les cases la seule case disponibles pour
la dame essai de cazan h3 on peut
détailler un peu pourquoi les autres
casses sont indisponibles
le clan f4 contrôler les cases e5 et g5
la dame des contrôles la case h5 et à
casey 4 et la 4g 4 ici le fougueux
4control la 4g 6 et les casses des 5 est
donc là on a fait le tour ne reste plus
que la casse
h3 pour la dame et john van der wiel n'y
a pas été donc on va analyser ce qui se
passerait voilà d'abord remonte
mentionné la partie on va maçonné la
partie donc vers vers dvi final choisi
de prendre
les français savent sur quoi il faudra
très logique france 5
comprendre l'âme pions prend en fou et
appréciant fut grande quand fu est ici
les noix les blancs ont une dame contre
deux pièces mineurs on rappelle que les
pièces mineurs c'est le cavalier ou le
fou ouais les autres cas c'est dans la
plaine de pièces que dans le tour et la
lame qui on prend ces 5 et l'a donc la
dame contre deux pièces mineurs un
cavalier un fou donc les blondes son nom
une position techniquement gagnante
qu'ils n'ont pas tardé à transformer
alors maintenant revenons à la position
du 20e coup on va y revenir directory
d'ailleurs tu grèce à la fin de la
partie vous verrez que la partie dure à
peine six ou sept coups de +16 où il ya
aucune aucun souci à se faire dans cette
position et là on nous allons envisager
maintenant dans cette position le
ku'damm h3 pas la seul coup qui a l'air
de sauvegarder la dame exactement ici à
laon la supposition
c'est qu'il y aurait eu tour j'ai un
échec
donc là indispensable roi vient ensuite
il n'y a pas d'autres coûts maintenant
on amène la dame de d1 1 h 5
alors là actions combinées la dame h5
plus le fou et 4 font une attaque doute
sur le curage cette même menace étant la
dame ici
en option on fait avec échec et mat à
cacher que matt une seule parade qui
tienne c'est l'avancée de ses pions qui
coupe la diagonale du fou ça comme l'un
des rendez vous aimez ça enlève une case
à la dame un sens relève d'une case clés
à la dame d'ailleurs oui donc petit
problème
petit problème c'était oui il semblerait
qu'ils en oublient dans notre analyse de
la position donc
je ne sais pas quoi attendre peut-être y
réfléchir nous allons mentionné l'erreur
qu'on a fait correct c'est un fils que
là on nous pensions qu'après deux fous
j'ai 2 la dame noire était enfermée en
fait il y as dame
h3 angers 4 cette fois ci ce sont les
noirs qui gagneraient donc nous allons
pas d'oublier table oublier d'aborder la
solution de jean pierre mercier
je n'ai pas regardé la solution de jean
pierre merci voilà je pense je pense
l'avoir trouvé en fait ça m'a été
soufflée dans cette position on va on va
priver la solution vous inviter à y
réfléchir
et avant de passer de passer de pression
on a une dernière interview intéressante
dans les interviews qui concerne
directement sur ce match voilà c'est le
dire le président du club de cannes star
le grand maître y vais réfléchir à la
solution vous inquiétez pas et donc
d'avenir le basique qui parle de ce
match et de ses activités à clame
d'ailleurs le massif
la fédération internationale des échecs
toujours à l'automobile club de france
place de la concorde et cette fois nous
recevons le président du club de cannes
le club de cannes un des clubs les plus
dynamiques en france d'amir leva cicor
bonjour dhamir alors le club de clad
kahn très dynamique notamment en ce
début de saison avec deux très jolis
matchs le premier match entre velay 19,4
chef et alberto david et maintenant
contre le 19 juin encore contre cette
fois un hollandais john van der wiel
comment ça se passe eh bien écoutez ce
qui est très intéressant dans une
confrontation à l'occasion d'un match
c'est un débat d'idées c'est un c'est en
fait une symphonie
ce n'est pas une partie comme dans un
tournoi open il y a une différence dans
les parties paires et impaires
il y à des variantes qui sont analysés
et donc c'est vraiment beaucoup plus
instructif pour les joueurs et
d'ailleurs les grands joueurs ne s'y
trompent pas et les supporters et les
amateurs ne s'y trompe pas car ils
apprécient les parties jouées en match
les parties jouées en match ce sont
toutes des parties où les ouvertures
sont mûrement réfléchies
c'est la grande différence avec les open
où les joueurs quelquefois essaye des
choses un petit peu dans les ouvertures
il ne dévoile pas tout leur toutes leurs
arm leurs secrets de fabrication et là
vraiment je suis très très satisfait de
ce combat qui est un combat d'olympisme
ils sont 1 de pureté et se donne à fond
il n'y a pas de danger financier
important et donc les joueurs se
préparent intensivement tous les matins
trois heures de préparation chacun
lorsqu'il termine la partie analyse
ensemble avec évidemment les amis du
club qui sont là les organisateurs
c'est un des ritable régal alors c'est
en égal mais c'est aussi pour quatre
chefs l'opportunité avec ses deux matchs
de gagner beaucoup de points elo et
peut-être de grimper de façon
significative au classement mondial
c'est la motivation de vladislav
évidemment et le club a tout fait pour
aider parce que c'est un excellent
ambassadeur pour le club c'est un garçon
qui a des qualités humaines des qualités
sportives des qualités de gentleman et
le club se devait de tout faire pour
aider vladislav organisé ces deux
matches le civ laddh arrive à
s'approcher à titiller les 2007 vous
comprenez bien qu'il rentre dans la
sphère du cycle à s'est refermée où
toutes les invitations arrive et c'est
la seule chance pour lui un jour de 2,2
d'affronter anand travnik ou garry
kasparov
ça c'est hyper intéressant et il ya
autre chose évidemment qu'organise le
club de cannes depuis des années
maintenant s'il ya le festival des jeux
je crois qu'il a lu en février avec
cette année je crois d'une très grande
surprise pour déjà pour cette année 2000
nous allons enfin enfin jouer dans la
plus belle salle peut-être de cannes est
peut-être une des plus belles de france
le fameux salon des ambassadeurs et les
joueurs qui vont jouer l'open bello
peines et les amateurs vont être dans
une salle de rêve aussi jolie que celle
ici
face à l'assemblée nationale alors je
dirais que c'est un grand merci
évidemment la ville de cannes au palais
de nous donner cet occasion grâce aux à
l'extension du nouveau palais nous avons
libéré des espaces
il faut dire que notre tournoi durant 13
années consécutives a été toujours d'un
haut niveau
tous les meilleurs joueurs français
ayant participé énormément de joueurs de
pointures internationales
il faut dire quelquefois il faut
l'avouer les conditions de jeu dans la
salle du moins 1 n'était pas à la
hauteur
vraiment du plateau que nous avions et
cette année les choses vont être
réparées alors au programme
etienne bacrot ambassadeur numéro un du
club qui va jouer contre anatoli karpov
le master ce pierre et vacances deuxième
édition avec seulement 32 joueurs sur la
ligne de départ et nous avons invité
évidemment votre prestigieux
collaborateurs et loire lange a
participé pour être parmi les 32 avec
une finale d'ailleurs ladislav a été
vainqueur l'an passé
donc on renouvelle cette formule est
ensuite open fit des et open pour lennon
fils et donc notamment donc ce match
thiennes bacrot contre anatoli karpov
après judit polgar etienne maintenant
s'affrontent à une montagne
anatoly karpov c'est l'homme des matches
impossible de se reprendre en match mais
moi je peux vous dire etienne va
l'emporter dans ce match car etienne est
dans une phase après disons un certain
plateau de l'année de l'adolescence que
l'on peut résumer l'année 98 et tiennent
en ce moment est dans une forme
éblouissante il a montré et sur le jeu
de deux pôles gars c'est à dire sur le
jeu de le terrain de la tactique c'est
lui-même qui s'est mis à sacrifier deux
pièces c'est extraordinaire
en ce moment nous sommes dans une phase
avec à la veille de l'année 99 avec les
nouvelles technologies avec les
ambassadeurs des échecs en france nous
sommes dans une phase absolument
excitante et franchement il est bon
aujourd'hui est d'être champion d'échec
lé bon d'être organisateurs et il est
bon également d'être dirigeant de la
fédération dernière le basique
merci bon succès à vous voilà donc d'un
mur de massy
vous le voyez les échecs à cannes c'est
dynamique donc eloi est ce que tu as
trouvé la solution au moins j'ai un
petit doute sur nos solutions
donc je propose de faire venir un
spécialiste donc super josé la rubrique
de josé
à l'accès
oui
et voilà nous accueillons donc josé dos
santos voir josé champion de portugal
junior 1980 12 12 12
bonsoir et voix et choisir si je crois
que j'ai été totale et champion de
france cette année dans l'année 4 one je
crois
j'étais chez remontrances jumelles en 92
la première fois alors que je décris aux
records de précocité a finalement une
promotion de la nommer 992 à
sucé-sur-erdre quand je serais tu es
champion junior alors je dis tout le
temps tu gagnes de gérer une solution à
proposer
nous combattons n'était pas la solution
donc là nous en sommes dans une autre
variante à peu près vingt six ans que
monte très vite et si on peut montrer
des chics et sur la vidéo je vois pas la
vidéo donc je connais ce n'est pas grave
l'échiquier y est voilà qu'elle j'osais
quelles qu'elles soient moins tu bats au
fait c'est exactement la méthode qu'on
finalement dont dans la rubrique céder
les candidats et ici il ya un candidat
intéressant qui est tour j'ai trois
tours j'ai un an gilles trois attaques
de la rejouer ici
dès que m donc le coût subtil que donc
le sco soutient qu'elle josé
effectivement voilà la variante s'arrête
ici tour j'ai trois étant le coup
gagnant donc pas de pas de souci tout et
tout est revenu dans l'ordre et pas de
bluff et donc d'ailleurs peut-être
ignorons qu'appréciant quand j'ai trois
là bon alors bien entendu il y avait un
clouage la dame clouant la dame
donc tu comprends h3 option plongé trois
conventionnés d'ailleurs est sanctionné
par même programme ici les blancs dont
gagne également la partie puisque
au lait maternel le matériel et c'est un
peu plus chaud mais l'analyse du sérieux
moi et ça c'est clairement ces blancs la
récupère et blanc récupère une pièce
après moi il est impressionnante et
c'est compliqué donc josé alors qu'est
ce que tu nous a préparés pour cette
rubrique
cette troisième rubrique et me bats
toujours fait c'est la une peut il la
dernière étape un peu de notre première
méthode qui est celle la liste des
candidats dont qu'on a vu c'est très
important
les candidats et donc on l'a vu avec
l'exemple même même pour trouver
cavaliers hkd par exemple c'est on verra
plus tard pour trouver les coudes
attaque on peut le faire grâce aux
candidats c'est c'est très bien donc là
en fait tu es en train de te référer à
la baronnie précédentes on a normalement
la partie la condamne à lise et il voit
camélia kath soit tour j'ai trois sont
des coups qu'on trouve grâce à la
méthode est candidat serra chercher un
peu les coups possibles avant d'analyser
donc là est ce qu'on peut mettre la
position
pour pour les internautes puisqu'ils
n'ont pas pu préparer cette position-là
qui n'est pas disponible en ligne
simplement qu'ils puissent voir de quoi
nous allons parler tout de suite voilà
tout à fait donc on va mettre
l'échiquier soit la relation vidéo voilà
donc c'est une position finalement mais
vas-y contre bath et donc la synth
position connue puisque c'est elle qui
reste alors ils granby le sens sacré ce
qui est qui et à l'éthique alors parce
que bon talent c'est un grand champion
du monde l'été champion du monde pour
une courte période mais quand même très
fort et qui reste lui
malheureusement c'est un peu le livre de
shoot moderne et il a toujours un peu
craqué je pense qu'ils auraient mérité
de champion du monde il n'a pas pu
malheureusement bon et maintenant il ne
pourra jamais puisque en quelle année
capitale
alors là je sais plus chanter un cheval
à 58 58 eh ben donc il est champion du
monde à l'époque où il joue cette partie
je voulais les blancs alors cette
position alors c'est toujours la même
chose donc on fait les ont fait les
candidats et pour finir un peu cette
première phase on s'intéresse à la
question quelle est la menace
on a dit qu'elle quelle est la menace la
mairie de réduire les candidats donc ici
les noirs menace tu peux le mentionner
le cavalier des 4 mais on peut aussi
mentionner notre facteur important c'est
la faiblesse du roi en g2 donc bon
moment maintenant c'est aux blancs de
jouer bien sûr d'accord puisque
l'ec le capital qui sinon se revoir très
très facile alors là il ya plusieurs
coups possibles plusieurs candidats il
faut tous les voir avant de jouer un
coup y avant d'analyser donc il ya
cavaliers b3 donc si un cavalier mais 3
rue paul loukou donc le cavalier s'en va
de l'attak il y à aussi cavalier f3 un
autre d'autres coups cavalli b5
également et le dernier coup de
cavaliers qui avait laissé 6 on a
éliminé au fait un coup quitté cap lc 2
donc et avec ses quatre coups candidats
il ya un coût de dames également dam des
cinq qui protège le cavaly d'oncle en
fait tu répertorie tous les coups qui ne
doit pas cavalier des quatre voilà tout
le côté ne perd pas de cave et les
quatre bien sûr bon il ya d'autres coups
un peu possible de cavaliers mais cela
ce sont les plus sûres nizon est donc à
première vue parce que mon à première
vue on regarde un peu toujours comme ça
et puis pour voir truc banques
donc on va commencer par cavalli b3 oui
parce qu'on est un peu près c'est donc
cavalier b3 maintenant donc on va donner
la solution ces dames de l'échec
donc là le meilleur coup ses rouages
trois mâts chaque fois de faire les
candidats pour les blancs et les noirs
mais là on donne les meilleurs variantes
et la 4e cat échec
le cookie qui tue pions prend 1,4 voyez
les qualificatifs sont efforcés de
l'argent pour maintenir une pression
thomas et dames f3 matt 25 fois c'est
très simple c'est incroyable de faire
mal comme ça on l'a et puis parce que
fait de la position du roi est très
faible et le couple dan et cavaliers
très très fort et donc on va encore le
voir avec on va encore le voir par
exemple dont cologne en avalant de
cavaliers cavalières trois dames eu deux
échecs roi h trois cavaliers f2 échec
donc le couple dame cavalli marche bien
roigé deux objets de revenir cavaliers d
un échec
un tout petit balai ouais donc roi je
crois toujours
c'est le plus solide dans les fins
maintenant cette fois-ci damev un échec
et le roi que j'ai monté roi g4 et
cavaliers 3 gagne les dames donc une
variante marriott à tiroirs quand même
mais assez c'est assez simple puisque
force et forcée voilà complètement force
et donc voilà et donc est ce qu'il faut
donner le lait on a le temps de regarder
autres candidats ou alors il faut
montrer la solution donc ici la solution
s'est alors avancé de jouer le fait
d'amener 5
le cavalier doit rester centrale et les
autres coûts de cavaliers perdent
également le cabinet en fait le cavalier
la dame devrait centrale pour pour
essayer de contrôler ex ante rôle
efficace qu après devront tous les
blancs instaure une petite menace
également
donc il faut jouer avec défense menace
donc ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'après
avoir éliminé tous les coups de
cavaliers on est venu à jouer l'unique
ou possible qui est donc de me dessine
et le fin de partie a été nul
alors la fin de partie je ne la connais
pas mais certainement sera pour la
prochaine fois je dirais même plus
intéressante avec peu de pièces on voit
qu'il ya encore des milliards il fait
tout le temps faire les candidats et
d'ailleurs ça aide et notamment le jeune
couple dans un car l'équipe est très
très dangereux coupe d'un cavalier c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus fort plus fort que
dame est fou
les maires si j'osais donc laser il y à
peine un point de prochaine lombrics
voilà tu va peut-être nous parlent et je
crois de
alors peut-être d'un portrait en fait je
vais alterner un portrait puis la
rubrique sur les candidats sur la
méthode mais maintenant ça dépend aussi
des internautes s'ils veulent envoyer
des messages pour signer missionnant
intéressés disons sur le chantier de
méthodes pourquoi pas sinon et bien
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour en
savoir plus sur le feuilleton la route
de josé et n'oubliez pas la cassette
vidéo
le best-of de diagonale voilà 1999 pour
la fin merci d'avoir suivi cette
émission donc en vente dans toutes les
têtes chez tous les bons revendeurs les
meilleurs moments de l'année
voilà merci au revoir à son projet
pour